to end the end is just about here for
fans awaiting the next installment of
the Star Wars saga the last Jedi will be
screened publicly for the first time
this evening in Los Angeles some of the
stuff that happens people gonna be not
oh my god
web sites throughout cyberspace have
been going into overdrive analyzing what
little is known about the last Jedi time
even put out a shot by shot analysis of
the official two minute trailer which
teases the dramatic meeting between the
series newest Jedi ray and Luke
Skywalker
it's been two years since the pair were
last seen the unspoken encounter came in
the final moments of the force awakens
atop the mountain of a lush deserted
island last May CBS's Mark Phillips made
his own Trek to that Island skellig
michael thank you very much
located seven miles off the southwest
tip of Ireland the island settled 1,300
years ago by Christian monks has become
a major tourist attraction the force
awakens' took home nearly 2 billion
dollars at the box office
disney is so confident in the last Jedi
that they're already printing money
specifically commemorative banknotes
I've seen this recently the last Jedi is
the second film in a trilogy that is
expected to wrap the skywalker Series I
am so excited is that cliche I have my
popcorn at the ready I'm gonna buy a
ticket my cab driver was talking about
this see Mark Hamill's she was again
it's a cultural moment it is it's and
everything everybody connects to it in
some way yeah I still remember seeing
the first one the music recall I
remember like the early moments of my
child there you go